Let's say you're socially shoes.
Okay?
So what happens when you're socially
anxious?
You go to a party,
your heart's beating,
why the party is a monster.
Why?
Because it's judging you and it's
judging you.
It's putting you low down the dominance
hierarchy because that's what a negative
judgment is.
And that interferes with your sexual
soul success.
And that means that you're being harshly
evaluated by nature itself,
right?
So you are confronting that the dragon
of chaos when you go into the social
situation.
And so what do you do?
You'd like this,
right?
You hunch over.
And that's low dominance.
I'm no threat.
It's like,
oh,
that's not going to get you very far,
you know?
But that's a logical thing to do in,
in the,
in the face of a tyrant.
So I'm no threat.
You know,
you look at the king and your dad,
I'm no threat.
I'm hunched over.
And then what's happening internally?
How are,
what are people thinking about me?
What are people thinking about me?
Or am I looking stupid?
Am I looking foolish?
Geez,
I'm awkward.
I hate being here,
man.
I'm sweating too much.
It's all internalized,
right?
It's all self focused.
The,
the eye isn't work.
The eye isn't working.
What do you tell people?
Stop.
Don't stop thinking about yourself
because you can't,
it's like don't think of a white
elephant,
white elephant,
white elephant.
You can't tell someone to stop thinking
about something because they get caught
in the loop.
What you do with socially anxious people
as you say,
look at other people.
Look at them.
Right?
Why?
Because if you look at them,
you can tell what they're thinking and
then you,
you're,
unless you're,
unless you're terribly socialized and
some people are,
some people have no social skills and so
the reason they can't go to a party is
cause they don't even know how to
introduce themselves.
Like they're just,
no one ever taught them how to behave.
And so they're really good
candidates for behavior therapy cause
you walk them through the process of how
you actually manifest the procedures
that are associated with social
acceptability.
But most people aren't like that.
They have the ability.
So if they're really introverted in high
in neuroticism,
they can usually talk quite well to
someone.
One on one.
Why?
Because they look at them on,
if I look at you,
it's another thing to do.
If you're ever speaking to a group of
people,
never speak to the group of people that
that doesn't exist.
You talk to individuals and then they
reflect for you the entire group because
they're all in trained.
So you look at one person,
they broadcast you what everyone's
thinking and you know how to talk to one
person.
So it's easy.
So as soon as you focus on the person,
not you push your attention outward,
use your,
I push your attention outward and you
start watching.
Well then all your automatic mechanisms
kick in and you start being awkward.
Cause if we're talking and I'm looking
here,
I don't know what you're gonna do next
and I'm going to put disjunctions into
the like,
they're like a bad chords and the melody
of our,
of our conversation.
And the reason is I'm not paying
attention.
So that's why the I is the thing at the
top of the pyramid.
It's like the thing that enables you to
win the set of all possible dominance
hierarchies is the I pay attention.
Pay Attention.
That's the critical issue.
That's why the Egyptians worshiped
horace.
That's why horace was the thing that
rescued.
Oh,
Cyrus.
From the,
from the depths.
It's the capacity to pay attention.
What do you pay attention to most?
What?
Your right hemisphere signals as
anomalous.
It attracts your attention.
It's like this isn't going quite right.
I'm not looking at that wrong.
That's what you look at.
What's not going right,
because that's,
see that's the terrible monster that
might eat you,
but it's also the place you get all the
information.
So that's why it's useful to have
discussions with your enemies because
they will tell you things you do not
know.
And that's such a great thing because if
you don't know them well,
you're not very smart,
are you?
You know,
there may be a time when you go
somewhere this,
that's the thing you need to know and
maybe your enemy will tell you why
you're such a fool,
you know,
on a bunch of other things that aren't
true too.
But even one thing that's accurate,
it's like,
yeah,
thanks very much man.
Maybe I'll do some work on that and I
won't have to carry that forward.
So,
and then that's part of the reason again
why the terrible predator.
It's always the terrible Predator that
has the gold.
It's like it's the person who delivers
the message you do not want to hear.
So it's rough,
it's rough,
but it doesn't matter.
Life is rough
to move forward,
you know?
I mean I've dealt with lots of people
who have anxiety disorders,
you know?
And one thing about people who have
anxiety disorders is they are not
mysterious to me.
I understand.
It's no problem for me to understand why
people have anxiety disorders or why
they're depressed or why they have
substance use problems.
The mystery to me is always why people
don't have all of those things at once.
Because everybody has a reason to be
anxious.
In fact,
we have the ultimate reason to be
anxious because we know that we're
vulnerable and we know that we're going
to die.
And how you can not be anxious under
those circumstances is a great mystery.
It's a massive mystery.
And that same thing applies with regards
to depression.
And then the same thing applies to some
degree with regards to drug and alcohol
abuse.
As I said last week,
there's plenty of reasons to drown your
consciousness and alcohol,
that's for sure.
We could refer to the aforementioned
anxiety and depression not least.
And so,
and the and the sorts of drugs that
people are prone to take our chemicals
that take the aspect of edge off the
tragedy of life.
So,
so
back to back to the issue of,
of of fear being Abraham is self
conscious if that's what this commentary
says.
But the thing is as he moves forward,
despite that he's self conscious and he
knows the danger but he moves despite
that.
And that's actually the appropriate
response in the face of actual non naive
understanding of what constitutes life.
Like if you're naive and you move
forward,
it's like,
well,
what the hell do you even know?
You know,
there's no courage in naivety because
you don't know what there is to stop
you.
You don't know what dangers you might
apprehend,
but to be aware of what it is that your
problem is.
So to be alert existentially,
let's say,
or to be fully self conscious means that
you're perfectly aware of your
limitations and how you might be hurt
and then to make the decision to move
forward into the unknown in the land of
the stranger.
Anyways,
that's the,
I would say that's one of the secrets to
a good life and I can say that really
without fear of contradiction.
I would,
I would say because the clinical
literature on this is very,
very,
very clear.
What you do with people who are afraid
and to some degree depressed,
but certainly anxious,
is you lay out what,
what they're anxious about first of all,
in in detail,
what is it that you're afraid of,
what might happen?
And then you decompose it into small
problems,
hypothetically manageable problems.
And then you have the person expose
themselves to the thing that they're
afraid of.
And what happens isn't that they get
less afraid.
That isn't what the clinical literature
indicates.
Exactly.
What happens instead is they get braver
and that's not the same thing,
right?
Cause if you get less afraid,
it's like,
well the world isn't as dangerous as I
thought it was.
You know,
silly me.
If you get braver,
that's not what happens.
What happens is,
yeah,
the World Damn worlds just as dangerous
as I thought.
Or maybe it's even more dangerous than I
thought,
but it turns out that there's something
in me that responds to taking that on as
a voluntary challenge and grows and
thrives as a consequence.
And there's no doubt about this.
Even the psychophysiological findings
are quite clear if you,
if you can,
if you impose a stressor on two groups
of people and on one group the stressor
is imposed involuntarily and on the
other group the stressor is picked up
voluntarily.
The people who pick up the stressor,
voluntary voluntarily use a whole
different psychophysiological system to
deal with it.
They use the system that's associated
with approach and challenge and not the
system that's a pro associated with
defensive aggression and withdrawal and
the system that is associated with
challenge is much more associated with
positive emotion and much less
associated with negative emotion.
It's also much less hard on you because
the defensive posturing system,
the prey animal system,
man would not thing kicks in.
It's all systems are go for you.
You know,
you're,
the gas is pushed down to the or the
pedal is pushed down to the metal and
the brakes are on.
You're using future resources that you
could be storing for future time right
now in the present to ready yourself for
emergency.
So there's,
there's,
there's nothing simple or trivial at all
about the idea of being called to move
forthrightly forward into the strange
and the unknown.
And there's real adventure that's
associated with that.
Right?
So that's an exciting thing,
which is part of the reason why people
travel and then also to see yourself as
the sort of creature that can do that is
willing to do that on a habitual basis
is also the right kind of tonic for,
I hate this word for your self esteem,
you know,
because the self esteem has nothing to
do with feeling good about yourself.
As a,
as I already mentioned,
there isn't necessarily a reason why a
priority,
you should just feel good about
yourself.
But if you can view yourself acting in a
courageous and forthright manner and
encountering the world and trying to
improve your lot and,
and,
and taking risks,
you know,
in a non naive way,
well then you have something that you
can comfort yourself with at night when
you're wondering what the whole damn
point of,
of your few tiled and miserable life.
And so,
and that's necessary because it's often
the case that you wake up at four in the
morning,
or at least sometimes the case that you
wake up at four in the morning when
things haven't been going that well and
wonder just what the hell the point is
of your few and miserable life,
you have to have something real to set
against that.
It can't be just rationalizations about
how you're a valuable person among
others,
even though that's true,
that's not good enough.
You need something that's more realistic
to set against that and observing
courage in yourself is definitely one of
the things that that that could help you
sleep soundly at night when,
when things are destabilized a little
bit around you.
So.